[Musique]
euh
notre corps monte dans notre cas à environ
160 165 degrés de
chaleur euh évidemment garde l'
activité microbienne super super active et au
bout d'un mois notre corps est à peu près
complètement transformé
il reste un peu d'os c'est
réduit c'est remis  dans le sol, il est
laissé reposer pendant un mois de plus
et lorsque nous avons terminé,
nous avons du sol que nous pouvons donner à la
crémation familiale prend 30 gallons de carburant et
pompe environ 540 livres de co2 dans l'
atmosphère à chaque crémation, nous avons donc
conçu un  système qui fonctionne à environ 90
% plus propre que
celui des images de
quand il était dans son groupe, ils s'appelaient
euh
[Music]
il a vraiment fait des recherches et il a décidé
que c'était ce qu'il voulait et qu'il
voulait redonner à la nature
vous savez  maintenant que j'ai suivi le
processus,
je suis tout à fait d'accord, je serai licencié
trois États qui ont légalisé
Washington était le premier, puis le Colorado
et l'Oregon, nous entendons dire qu'il y a
environ quatre ou cinq employés supplémentaires  ceux
qui l'ont actuellement dans leurs livres
cherchent à ouvrir ces portes à
la réduction organique naturelle
[Musique]